the perfect floor and0 his last four starts Aon
e blad's going to send one right to the glove of
AA he saw it all the way so we'll get another
face off here and they have a a serious belief
going all the way to the Stanley Cup finals
last year against the Vegas golden knights
out of the corner Matthew kachuck and right back
to the front benett as this one will be played
around holding on to it is Veri takes it right to
the net and knocked away there I cannot believe
there wasn't a penalty on the play and it's been
something else all four lines contributing here
that's that's the big one for me last year it
was Clayton Keller and Nick smtz that provided
45% of the offense oh he's one of the best
in the league no question about it dery and
that's handled by Sergey barosi Act of the line
kessering good keep into the corner CER foot out
High kessle ring Wier and good traffic in front
but able to see it bosski just a a simple hard
game and always so dangerous when you play a
team below you in the standings kulakov will
bring it in for Eckman Larsson he shoots and a
stop and a rebound oh there is patent Oliver Ean
Larson suer breaks back he's got some room Jason
CER he shoots and MOSI Larson long time coyote
back to back the guy can do it all Zack San will
play it in behind and at carcone on the curl and
that's stopped by bosi kessing fourth among rookie
defenseman in points so far this one to the front
for haggy and he's stopped by belela good keep
Bennett now working the right wing boards across
it goes bsing shoots that one caught somebody in
front three shot shut outs here at mullet Arena
that's second best in the NHL Keller with a sharp
angle shot this one's going to be covered former
Tampa Bay Lightning Blair plays it right back
to the front and B it and it's covered by Vela
oh what a play there by how they've cashed in
on it based on the difference what we saw a
year ago congratulations to you Matt we're in
trouble if I'm the fourth star that's that's
all I can say bu that will bring it in and it's
denied Bennett will turn the other way and here
comes Florida again cter HEI leading the rush
and that's broken up Veri gets it back and he
scores Carter Veri and he's been all over it here
in the opening 11 minutes or so and Florida with
a one- nothing lead time no call on the play
and this is a little bit of a broken play the
coyotes have the puck and they lose it it was
bustad that tries to kick that puck up to his
stick turns it over and Veri right here in the
middle of the ice you uses Dumba as a screen and
blows it past carela Mela and unfortunate play
here really no fault on the play retrieval by
Veri mour and now barov P out high on tour right
back to the front and hit the pipe power play M
Kar parked in front right off the pipe to the
left of Amela redirection there Sam Reinhardt
fourth in the National Hockey League and
goals with 23 Rodriguez for the line e black
Ean Larson down low again curling Rodriguez he
got hammered that time in front CES they they
allow Rodriguez maybe a little bit too much
time and space Oliver at Larson down low and
there was a man open for the Panthers in that
high slot comes around Moser with a shot that
off the did that go off the pipe I think it
went off the post and a one nothing Panthers
lead and it brings it in denied melli the other
way maybe a two-on-one he's got bu on the left
melli shoots and a stop baski off the Bennett
turnover right there 200 ft from your net it's
a two-on one the other way bues that coming
down the other side and pretty well played
by the Florida Panthers that was barkoff as a
forward took away the pass across to buad and
Matias melli let and now bennettan Larson
across Bennett shot goes wide Ean Larsson
again Deni here's an opportunity picked by
kerfoot brings it along Lawson cruss back
to kerfoot he scores Alex kerfoot a shorty is
tied it handed goal and there's the turnover
by Oliver emman Larson Off to the Races Alex
kerfoot gets it back from Lawson Krauss what
a feed and how about the sweet Ms of kerot
look at him feather this one up top he waits
for boski to go down and then he elevates this
right under the bar oh my what a goal his fifth
of the Season what a and they get it set up for
Baron out High it goes across Veri towards the
front bouncing around Coyote's looking for a
clear oh what a play there by Rodriguez I think
barov was caught off guard on that play now
barov again comes across and off the pipe Sam
Reinhardt and heill skated it along through
Center for barov hard ofer hay he's got the
Florida goal to the front they score sharp
angle and it might have been red deflected
as that reinhardt's gold Tyson it's th% 2-1 har
didn't even know he scored this he's got a smirk
on his face I think he thought he ran out of real
estate and barov just throws it at the net and
look at that redirection wow maybea gets caught a
little bit too tight in his net but you still you
got to protect that near post and I think that's
what he's doing and that redirection sends it the
other Sam Bennett in the draw against C coyotes
win it oh great hit hay that time on kessle ring
goes right to the front they SWAT away at it
and they score and they got another one and
Matthew could suck I believe will'll get it and
it's 3-1 Florida be a nightmare to play against
here's the hit for heggy on kessle ring sends him
flying gets the puck back they work it around the
horn up top and there's the redirection in front
and I think kessle ring puts this puck in maybe
into his own net right here yes that's exactly
what happens Matthew could Chuck's going to get
this goal he's the last one to touch it before
kessle ring Coyote's pulled a goal tener extra
attacker is out valami he'll Beat It Out High
across it goes schz a little too hot coming
in that time from melli and this one will be
cleared away and towards the empty net and it's
in and the floor of Panthers have pretty
much iced it yeah I would imagine that
that's going to do it you had to do it you
had to go up the early pole and it's just
a a one battle there and warling what a play
there wins the battle down low in the corner
and then just goes to ice it really a healthy
dose of them on this five game home stad yeah
it's just been waves of white here tonight K
with a shot and a big save Bowski and that's
that's the other problem when you get a great
look Sergey barosi has pretty much slammed the
door yeah and that wasn't the case for for quite
a while with boski right I me yeah they're kind
of going back and forth between goenda has
taken over that net since last year Anton
londell tracking at that time was Vela but a
victory they'll be on their way to Colorado in
Vegas back out high forsing at
the horn and that's going to do it